Hi, everyone. Thank you for joining us for our opening webinar for Imaging Science
program. This program is a celebration of science photography and making
observations of the world around us through photography.
So through this webinar, photography tutorials, we're going to be and other
social media posts, we're going to be giving you the tools that you need to
take some really interesting observations of the world around you and
share them with us. And with that, I'm going to head. I'm going to hand this off
to Erika Reinfeld, who is the the Outreach Coordinator at the Koch Institute. So
take it away, Erika. [Erika] Thank you so much, Brian. All right, let me pull my screen up
here. And thank you to everyone who's filled out the poll. We'll be looking at
the results of that in just a little bit. But let me...I'm going to start things off
with an intro and then we'll jump into our conversation with our expert
photographers. Alright, so hopefully everyone can see this now,
And before I move into introducing our speakers, I just want to tell you a
little bit about who I am and why I'm here and I'm gonna go. I'm gonna move the
poll off the screen and let you end that Brian. If you are in control of that.
Alright, so I am a scientist by training. I'm an educator in practice. And as you
can see most of my career has been spent looking at interdisciplinary work. Alright so hi
this is me. This is me in our public galleries here at the Koch Institute at
MIT. And that's actually what I want to talk to you about first. This is the, this
is I think the main reason Brian asked me to be a part of this webinar. And so,
as part of my role I manage the public galleries at the Koch Institute, which is
MIT's Cancer Research Center. It's a convergence of biology and engineering.
And one of the central exhibits in our public galleries is the image awards
exhibition. So that's every year, scientists and researchers from MIT's
Biomedical Engineering life sciences submit images and a
panel of judges, who are made up of scientists and artists and others, choose 10 images
from we get about 150 every year and they select 10 of those images to be put
on display in these eight foot tall light boxes on Main Street in Cambridge. So
what you see here is a snapshot from our 2016 exhibition. There's a cryogenically
frozen stem cell on the left and then where Asha's standing. This is a
mosaic of synthetic polymers that are interacting with various cell types
taken with fluorescence microscopy. So any image in the display has to meet two
key criteria, it has to be visually engaging and it has to be scientifically
compelling. It can't just be a pretty picture. It has to tell a good story
about real research. So in Asha's case, she was examining these interactions between
synthetic materials and cells to identify promising candidates for new
materials to be used in biomedical research and clinical applications.
So it's a screening experiment which serves as a bridge between discovery and
innovation, ideas and actions, and that's one of the themes I think we want to
talk about in our exploration of science photography that connection between
ideas and action. But before we do that I want to show you another view of this
image, which is juxtaposed with images of exploding stars taken by the Chandra
X-ray observatory. This was put together by a former colleague of mine, Kim Arcand
and I think it's just a really beautiful illustration of how scientific imagery
can be used to make connections between different disciplines. So on that note, if
if you, if you were reading my earlier slide you'll see that I spent a fair bit of
time in the museum world looking at how people make sense of scientific images;
do they see them as information or do they see them as art and well worth a
graduate degree, the answer, of course, is yes, they do. And so, to illustrate that I
have one more comparison that I want to show you. So this is, the image on the
left was taken by the Hubble Space Telescope to commemorate the 15th
anniversary of the satellite's launch. It shows a star forming nebula in the
constellation Serpens and then on the right is a
painting, I admit it, It's not a photograph, by Thomas Moran.
Elizabeth Kessler from Stanford has pointed out how the decisions that the
scientists made in the colors and the framing of images taken with cameras on
the Hubble Space Telescope really invoke these 19th century paintings and
photographs as well in both their composition and theme. So this kind of
blue sky background and the towering pillars and the light reflecting around
them. It represents scientific knowledge about the nebula where the stars are
being born, but they also call to mind this exploration of new frontiers. So,
with that connection between art and science in mind, I'm going to set aside the
fancy telescopes and microscopes and leave you with some more down to earth
pictures as I introduce our first speaker.
I'll introduce Felice Frankel who is a research scientist in the departments
of chemical engineering and mechanical engineering here, or there, at MIT. She's
an award winning science photographer and her most recent book is "Picturing
Science and Engineering" and it's published by MIT Press.
She teaches an online edX course, Making Science and Engineering Pictures, A
Practical Guide to Presenting Your Work. I've known Felice for a number of years
now, we've worked on both education workshops and on image and on this image
awards project. And so, I am delighted that she's going to be our first speaker
and share her experience as a science photographer. [Felice] Wonderful, can, can, can
you hear me. [laughs] It's wonderful to be here.
I want to thank Erika and and Brian for inviting me. I'm really delighted to do
this on a beautiful day like today and wrap our head around something that is
beautiful and something that is somewhat of a distraction if I could call it that,
but it's it's a real joy to be with all of you. And thank you for coming. I am now
I am going to share. I hope play my screen. And thank you, Erika and Brian for inviting
me. I'm so delighted and I can't wait to talk to
Keith and look at his amazing pictures which we're all going to be
astounded by. But my whole thing is going to try to explain to you why I do what
I'm doing. Goethe wrote, "that which we know . . . we have
first seen." Well, let me tell you, when I make photographs I see things that I've
never seen before, obviously. But I also see that it is a
means of discovery. I'm constantly asking questions whenever I take a picture of
some sort of scientific phenomenon. This is an old picture that I did not take
from many years ago, this kind of started me in my whole new world taken out of
from a lab that George Whitesides ran it at Harvard. It's a little complicated, but
I'll quickly tell you that it is water that is spreading out on a surface and
stopping at what we're calling hydrophobic lines. That's what started me
on my whole new journey because that's a picture that they made. And I said to
them, we could do better. And we did. This is the same phenomena where the
hydrophobic lines are preventing the water from blending together. That is in
fact what the science is about. This was my job, to help them communicate the
science better. This is Alice Nasto's image of material that she made that
she's studying in mechanical engineering. It's a fine image. This is the image that
I made of the identical material. I hope you see the difference. If you don't see
the difference, I'm in real trouble. But basically what I'm trying to do is
engage you to look more clearly at the at the research. Here's an image that I got off
of the of online and it's a picture of something called ferro fluid. This is the
picture that I made many years ago of ferro fluid. That I guess people still
enjoy looking at. Ferro fluid is oil suspension of small iron
particles. And when you put magnets next to it, it responds to the magnetic field.
I made this for book that George Whitesides and I did called "On The
Surface of Things". It - for me, most of this is about getting you to see and to first
look to engage you and to get you to understand that making beautiful images
and honest images, which I could get to at the end, is a means of engagement,
which I think is critical at this point of our lives. We've got to engage people
into our what is going on in the research labs and that's why I wrote the book
"Picturing Science and Engineering". It's for researchers, but there's a lot of
photography basic photography in it and I'm unabashedly introducing you to the
book. I hope you could take a look at it. You can use a flatbed scanner. It's quite
extraordinary what you could do with a flatbed scanner at the end if you set the
DPI correctly. We I talked about using backgrounds that kind of inform what it
is that we're looking at. I show a lot of microscopic images and how using
certain techniques and microscopy could advance the way it looks. And also,
frankly, getting you to look. That's what I'm trying to do. And the other part of
the book is all about the fact that science, in fact, is everywhere and I
suggest that when you make pictures of everything around you, it's a means of
getting you to ask questions. What is it, what is it that exactly I'm seeing? If
we had if we had more interactivity, I would ask you what it is that you think you're
looking at. And what you are looking at is the glass cover of a sautéing pan, and
I'm sautéing different peppers. The thing about this example is that I made it
with my phone and years ago, I used to tell the scientists, you really can't
take great pictures with your phone. Well, I've changed my mind.
I,  it's quite remarkable. Even walking down Comm Ave. I
remember distinctly seeing these trees for whatever reason they were wrapped
around with cellophane and I was looking at these assemblies of drops around the
crease. There is a scientific reason for the reason why that they are lining up.
Everywhere is science, and why not start making pictures of it. This is just more
fun. I got this device where I put my phone on the microscope. It was
it it was it was a device that easily puts it, allows you to see it. And these are just
coffee bubbles that are kind of doing their thing.
I'm also very involved with finding the metaphor. Sometimes you actually cannot
always take images of what the science is so trying to find some sort of
photographic metaphor. In this situation we're trying to describe what
binary means, this is the the way computers talk to each other. This is the
inside of a music box and the notes go on off, on off, and that is a suggestion
of a metaphor. Here's where I am, in fact, putting a lot of pieces together of
photographs to make an image that actually doesn't exist. The image exists,
but the thing that you're seeing doesn't really exist. Hopefully it's telling you a
story of something called remote epitaxy, which is too complicated to go into. But
these are all pieces of pictures that I put together. But in the end, I always
discuss with the researchers to maintain the scientific integrity in your images.
And that is a long conversation that perhaps we'll have at some point. For
example, when I made this picture of a yeast colony out of Gerry Fink's lab,
what I decided to do was to delete the petri dish, because I was blown away at
what was going on in this yeast colony. The detail was astounding, and I
wanted you to only pay attention to that. So I deleted
the petri dish. The question is, was I permitted to do so. And that is again a
long conversation that perhaps we might have someday. I say yes because the data
was not manipulated. This is the data, not the petri dish. So there we go, there's a
little hint of what I do. And it's a real joy to be with you guys.
I will stop sharing.
[Erika] Thank you so much Felice. Alright so what we want to do
now is turn things over to Keith and he'll give you a little taste of what he
does. I think those of you out there will notice that we've we've chosen these two
folks for very particular reasons they complement each other beautifully. So
we're going to hear from Keith momentarily. And then we'll then we'll have a little
discussion, we'll get the two of them actually talking to each other about
the science photos and we'll start to take some questions from your audience
from you in the audience. Again, using the Q and A  feature. So let me introduce Keith.
Keith is a celebrated underwater photographer working at the intersection
of art, science and technology to showcase the visual complexity of
underwater environments from coral reefs to coastal rivers to the wide open sea.
He is an assistant professor of photography at SUNY the Fashion
Institute of Technology and a visiting artist at Massachusetts Institute of
Technology Sea Grant and the recipient of the Ernest F. Hollings Ocean Awareness
Award. I met Keith  probably almost a year ago because one of his planktonic
images is currently on display in the Koch Institute public galleries, so he
has a beautiful image of dinoflagellates and I got to talk to him
about the story behind it, but he takes a lot of wonderful pictures and I'm going to
let him tell you what he does.
[Keith] Oh. Thank you very much for inviting me here. Can
you guys all see me and see my screen?
[Erika] Yes, good to me.
[Keith]Okay, good.
[Brian] Looks good.
[Keith] So thank you, Erika and Brian. It's wonderful to be here and I have to say
it's just so inspiring to follow Felice, her stunning images and the
photographic process. So it's a real honor to be here, so thank you. Um, I
thought I would talk today about what it's like working with conservation
based organizations and being fortunate to travel around the world to use the
art of photography and ocean photography, in particular, to inspire awareness in
conservation. This picture here is an aerial photo of tropical coral reef from
about 1000 feet within the remote Fijian Islands of Totoya. The photograph
was captured on board a small helicopter with the doors removed
sitting outside the helicopter. I was harnessed and tethered in with the wind
blowing and you could uh communicating with the pilot via headsets to get the right
pitch angle and image here. For the next few minutes I'd like to take you on a
journey beneath the waves. Underwater photography is a challenge. We're limited
by air, light, time, depth, animal behavior, just to name a few of the constraints. I
like this image of me diving because it a captures the strobes
illuminating the reef. At depth the wavelength of red is absorbed and the
ocean appears of blue gray, but with the addition of light, I'm able to reveal
vibrant colors. In the Galapagos Islands, I was on an assignment focusing on
biodiversity in sharks. As you began to swim back to the boat,
I observed a large aggregation of sea stars along the vast open sandy bottom.
The Galapagos is known for its bio diverse marine ecosystems. It's full of
mystery and intrigue. But the colors of these sea stars are natural, but they
revealed by the light of the strobe. Wildlife photography is about hours, days,
weeks, maybe even years of patience, followed by an instant of action. In
this photograph of a juvenile frigate bird diving to catch a fish is an
example of that. It was a behavior I observed and spent two days waiting in
shallow water with the lens pre focused, strobes above and below the water.
Frigate birds never land in the water. These birds are unbelievable. They
accelerate downward focusing on the fish when they get near the surface they
virtually stall. They place their head in the water, they switch between surface
vision underwater vision without blinking, catch the fish and then fly
away all in an instant. I stopped the lens, snapped the picture, looked at back,
and with a little bit of luck, I managed to get just this photo here. There're
also unexpected moments. Within the tentacles of a jellyfish is a school of
juvenile Trevally that seek shelter. If you look closely, you can see that,
you can see them right in the tentacles. To capture this image I
inverted myself underwater giving the fishes' perspective of what life must
look like through the waves into the clouds in the sky. Oftentimes I
collaborate with scientists and I often experiment with
other ways to visualize marine environment. This photo, one of my
colleagues using a fluorescent strobes to survey the coral reefs. The
psychedelic colors emitted by fluorescence light showcase another way
of looking at art in nature. While at the same point, the colors may lead to a
deeper understanding about the health of our corals. Sometimes I'm on assignments
in Indonesia or other places around the world
diving with scientists setting out to find and discover new possible species
of coral. This is one that's being described as a flower like pattern that
is unlike any other known species. People often ask, "What is it like to travel
with you on assignment?" and actually the most stressful part of my job is so
nervously checking all the luggage and bringing all the equipment everywhere  I
need to go. And just to give a sense of the kind of equipment that I have, these
are the housings that are all broken apart as they're ready to be cleaned and
assembled. I'm currently working on a multi year project entitled "Space to Sea
— A Photographic Journey into Stellwagen Bank National Marine Sanctuary",
just 25 nautical miles off the coast of Boston. It's part of a Hollings ocean
awareness award to showcase the surprising diversity of marine life off
our coast. To accomplish these images as part of my
process, I'm working with students to modify and prototype wireless camera
systems that enhance image making. We're bringing students into the field to
experience the local marine wildlife. Our process is to conduct plankton tows.
Bring the living samples back to the lab to be photographed under a microscope.
And we're inspired by the work of scientists at MIT Sea Grant, where we're
experimenting with a variety of photo microscopy image making techniques. This
image was created adding a drop of milk on the slide and just
filming the dynamic flow visualization created by this Clione or pteropod.
There are other cool animals that are all alien like a plankton living
in the ocean. This is a larval crab. And if you look closely, you can see its
compound eyes that are blue. Soon this creature will drop to the sea floor
bottom, sea floor bottom and become a tiny full formed crab. As a wildlife
photographer, I apply my image making skills to the micro scale. This
composition of three Ceratium is currently on exhibit at the MIT Koch Public
Galleries, and once the university's back open,
I encourage all of you to join and visit. On this one magical day, working with a
team of scientists, naturalists, and boat captains, I slipped into the water with a
wetsuit, snorkel, 360 multi camera system, looking to film what we thought was a
Basking Shark, moving on the surface. To my surprise, instead of encountering a
Basking Shark, it was an enormous 3000 pound Great White Shark, later identified
as Large Marge. I did the only thing I know how to do, which is keep the camera
stable and captured 17 glorious seconds of footage from tip to tail that can be
viewed in immersive virtual reality experience. Photography really has the
power to change our understanding of the world around us and it is my lifelong
goal to use the artistry of underwater photography to transform public
perception. That sparks our imagination inspires conservation and builds a local
stewardship about the extraordinary underwater wildlife and to connect
residents in New England with the local marine wildlife just off our shores.
Thanks.
[Erika] Thank you so much, Keith. Alright, I think what I'd love to do now is bring
Keith and Felice back on the screen, both of them together
and I see some questions are starting to come in on the Q and A, but I'll just start
things off. To note that, so we've seen a huge, even in what 10 minutes, a huge
diversity of subjects, of equipment, of ideas, environments. And so we could talk
for hours and hours about the specifics of each of those things, but in thinking
about it as a collection of science photographs, all these things have things
in common. They're good science photographs. So in your mind as a
photographer, what makes for a good or great science photo. [Felice] Gulp. [Erika] I like to
start with the easy ones.
[Felice] Well, yeah. Looking at Keith's work. There's your answer.
I mean, it's just a, you know, you want to, you want to look. I think that's the
first thing. What do you think Keith?
[Keith] Absolutely. I think the power of
observation is so critical. I mean, I think so often people think you just go
into the field. You just take a picture and you just find these moments, but
really it's a matter for me watching and learning observing
and after watching it for a while, you begin to be able to at least predict
moments in the wildlife in the things that are happening. And so I think that I
agree with you 100% Felice. Observation is probably the most
important and pre visualizing what you want to make for an image.
[Felice] And and yet at
the same time, leave open the surprises.
[Keith] Yeah.
[Felice] You know that picture that I made an
eternity ago, ferro fluid. When I put those magnets under the glucky material
I had no idea that I was going to find those shapes happening. I had some idea,
but and don't you find that you know, you can kind of get lost in the process, that
once you start seeing things that you didn't imagine, you kind of stay with it
and maybe even get better pictures as you go along.
Do you think?
[Keith] Absolutely. I think, you know, there's so much of the world where
you're, you know, you're trying on something and then your eye gets open to
another way of doing something and you follow into capturing those images or,
you know, I think in part that's even why collaboration is so wonderful. You learn
something a little bit new and then you try and experiment. And while so often
for me, I have a mental map of what I want to photograph. I mean so often that
isn't what I see. It's the other things that happened in sort of being ready for
those opportune moments of life just sort of shifting for those that are
prepared for that is really where life gets very exciting for me.
[Felice] Well you
see it in your photographs. You're, you're passionate about it and we feel it because
it's so remarkable. The way you do that. So, your, your work. The main difference
among a bazillion other things is that I am in control of my images. I, you know,
basic, basically I work in a studio where I control the lighting. And
whatever else I can in fact control. You are
certainly in control technically, up
to a point, but you never know what's going to happen at the last minute, you
have to figure, you have to be prepared as your equipment appears as if you're
quite prepared. There is a question from somebody, what,
what kind of camera do you use for undergrad, undergraduate [laughs], that's funny. I'm dealing
with undergraduates right now. What what camera are you using?
[Keith} I use a Canon 5D Mark 4, but as I
like to say, and I use a CNC underwater housing and dual YS250 strobes. But
what I like to tell people is, is that it's not the camera that makes the
photograph. It's the photograph itself. And I think
when you look at Felice's and certainly I feel for myself, but a lot of it is
about making an image, and there's always a fancier camera. There's always more
lights. There's always more equipment and always just adds complication. And I
think that so much of image making is learning how to actually create the very
thing you want to be creating and I can't stress this enough, I spend a lot of time,
even just waiting on repetition of animals, doing the same behavior because
if I see it once, I try and capture that again. And I'm sure in the studio, you
start to see things and then tweak it, just a little bit here and there.
[Felice] Yeah, and
[Keith] life is full of that constant adjusting and nuance, which is what makes
photography so fun.
[Felice] So fun. I'm glad you use the words fun, it should be.
[Erika] Yeah. Now in this
process, though, you're making some editorial decisions right. You're
deciding something. I'm going to photograph this and I'm not going to photograph that.
How do you make that decision?
[Keith] That's called I'm stressed always on
that because sometimes in life, there are these moments where everything is
happening at once. And how do you focus or how do you even know where to stand.
And at some point experience gives you how to position yourself where
you're more likely to see success than less. But so much of it is a matter of
sort of focusing on once I commit to something I focus on that and try my
best to to work that problem through visually. And I tend to, you could see in
my images that I shoot up to in sequence that it's about like really moving and
positioning and making something better. Sometimes you get it just on the first
glance like that Frigate Bird. But but I waited for that shot and was prepared
for it, but in other instances, if it's stationary sometimes I'm
tinkering with lights, I'm trying to move myself, I'm making stability and so
there's a lot of work to make the image just the way I sort of, I see it at that
moment, and I wonder Felice if that's your same process too.
[Felice] It's a little
different because I sort of, I have an assignment to depict a particular
phenomenon. And in a way, it's it's giving me a parameter to work within which I
enjoy that. Otherwise, you could go crazy, you know. And the thing.
And the thing about. And the same thing with you, but I, I understand the science of what I'm photographing.
I have a science background so not as deep as the scientists know,
understands. But at the very least, I can have, what I would I do is I have a
conversation going with the researcher and try to understand the real, bring
it down to the essence of what it is that you're trying to say. And so I'm limited
in that it's it's not about making it pretty. I think science is already
beautiful. It's just revealing the beauty that's
already there. But for me it's more, it's stripped more stringent in
a way.
[Keith] You know, it's just a beautiful way of describing it. And I think it's really a
visual language of removing the essence to just get at the core of how you want
someone's eye to move to understand the very things you want to convey
photographically, visually, it's very powerful.
[Felice] Very.
[Erika] There's a question in the ,
in the Q and A about modification of photographs. After you've got that shot,
what do you do to then present it and this gets into the scientific integrity
that you were talking about. But this, you have this, these raw images and you know,
at National Geographic is going is she's saying the editor says we don't want
things that are stitched together. We want minor adjustments only. How do you
tell a clear story and preserve the integrity of the raw image?
[Keith] I mean, I
think that's the art of photography is, is using the right equipment to get the right job and get the
right photo and so all of my photos that you have seen
have not been altered in really any way other than just some minor levels and
stuff like that. I don't crop in. The lenses, the choice
of what I'm using, in my ability to interact with the animals to get there
and editors, and when you're looking to sort of document something you have to
be true to what your image is. If you're in a fine art gallery or it's
abstraction and you're not documenting you know you feel free to manipulate and
do as you wish, but you certainly have to acknowledge that.
Um, the, the key part is,
again it comes with practice and experience doing that. And one of the
things that digital gives you that's so wonderful is that as you learn, if you
see you keep cropping in, then you need a different lens or you need to get closer
to your subject. If you see that the colors are always blown out, then you
need to adjust your lighting so you can learn on the fly. For what you tend to
like as an artist as a photographer to make those adjustments and help yourself
in the future so that you're improving over time.
[Felice] Yeah, and, and you know this, this I
have a whole chapter on image manipulation because I am
documenting research, I am very, very limited to any sort of manipulation or
an enhancement. There are guidelines that the journals suggest that you don't
do. But when I do anything, like for example, when I deleted the petri dish, I
always say that I have done the following, whenever that in the
caption, I do not consider myself an artist. I would never, I would never show
that image without somewhere saying that this is what I've done. And so there are,
there are rules in science and the problem is if you really, really
think about photography itself is a manipulation of reality. You know, the
camera that you use is going to give a different picture than my camera. And so
the, the essence of photography is you are manipulating what we're seeing. Yeah,
it's an issue.
[Keith] It's illusion, it's, I mean, it's clear. And that's what makes
photography so powerful is that you can create a point of view through an image
in many ways. You know, I can be close in a reef scene. For instance, you could
be close to fish and give an illusion that there are fish everywhere all
around, but maybe it's just this one rock that has some. And so your point of
view on what you're documenting or really has, helps to tell the story
and, you know, for me that's that's the fun of it is the perception of what
people see. Oftentimes you know on the side of a road there's like a, you know,
you'd see like a hawk or something. And sometimes you take out a long lens and
you photograph and you think you're in the middle of nowhere, but you're right
in an urban city you know it's it's really fun.
[Erika] Yeah, I'm seeing a lot of questions about
specific equipment and editing tools. So though that's something that people are
interested in. But also, I'm hearing, what tips do you have for getting the
most out of cameras on a phone?
So for for this everyday photography
[Felice] Right, um, the
first thing is, use it a lot. And more important after you use it, edit, you have
got to start looking at how you're making the pictures, and in that process
you will get to be a better photographer. You'll see that you left, you see, the
problem is for all of us is that we know what we want to look at and we're
assuming that the viewer outside of ourselves is going to see what we see.
But when you have a tree branch growing out of somebody's head, the viewer is
going to see that even though you didn't see it when you took the picture. So I
think that, you know, there's not a whole lot you could do that, I can do with my
what I call my real camera. But the beauty of the phone is that you could
quickly make an image with which I, I could not, I couldn't have taken that, those
pepper, in that pepper image 20 seconds later, because the picture was gone.
So it is in fact the wonderful part about having a phone, but you in the
end I really think you have got to start paying attention and looking at them and
start deleting them. Because I can you know my, my colleagues, not my
colleagues, but my friends. They have so many images. They don't even know where
to even look and it's, you know, they're not learning anything. And I think that's the
key to learn something.
[Keith] Yeah, I agree with that. And I would just add, I think, to
think about intent of what what do you want to show with this image. I think
one mistake people do a lot is, they just push the button constantly and are just
shot. Shot. Shot. Shot. Shot. Shot. Shot, shot and then hope for one of them to be right.
But if you pause and look at which one you like and then begin to ask yourself,
what do I want to say with this picture? What would be important to me, you know,
what is the main focus? What is around it? Do you want movement? Those are all
elements that go through my mind all the time in taking a picture. So I would use
it more as what story do you want to say, shoot, shoot a lot but not with intention,
shoot. Not just, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom,
but rather shoot lots of things in your daily life and ask yourself which ones
you like. And have fun with it. I think the most important thing of all, I could
recommend to everyone is there's nothing I like more than having an assignment
and having to go do my photography and that joy and love is what you should
really focus on.
[Erika] What have you learned from a photo that you've taken where
you've looked at this and said, oh, I know what I want to do next, or I, I know what
I shouldn't have done or what I, what I want to avoid? How do you use your own
photographs as a learning tool?
[Felice] There's a lot that I shouldn't have done, believe me. Which in
fact is, this is why looking at your pictures is a means of getting to be a
better photographer. It's for me, it's mostly technical issues that I've
screwed up on. And the fun thing is that you as you make the mistakes you get to
be better. What else is new? It's like with everything in life right.
[Keith] Yeah, I think that is couldn't be more correct, you have to look at what
you take and really study what is working for you and what isn't. And the
other thing that I think people just credit is I practice an awful lot. I
think I practice with the dexterity of my hand, my strength, my being able to
hold things up. And if you want an easy analogy I would think of it as a golfer.
You know, I can putt, I'm not particularly good, but people still, Tiger Woods still
putts all day long, every day practicing and stuff. And I think there is a muscle
memory that happens on this and I do do a lot of, I spend a lot of time staying,
using the equipment frequently and being very comfortable with all of the
interactions of it. I think that helps out a lot.
[Felice] Yeah, and you know, and
you know it's not going to work. Because they because you've done it, you've made the
mistake and that, in a way, I find that I'm,
I'm a better photographer than I
used to be. I mean, when I don't feel that way, then I think I'm I better give
up, but I know that I shouldn't do a particular thing because it's not going to
work. So I in in a way I save time.
[Keith] Right, and that's the other thing is to not hold
yourself to a standard, to allow images not to work and to recognize that, you
know, a lot of times I've tried things, it doesn't work out. Hopefully it leads
to something that does, but everything isn't an instant have an answer. There
are many problems that take time to work through or years of life to be able to
build towards those achievements. It's not just an immediate one day
gratification, rather a life of of working on it.
[Erika] My goodness, this sounds a lot like
the process of doing science. [Felice] Yeah. [Erika] Imagine that. We have a question along
those lines from the the Q and A here.
Saying in the field of bio-art,
the cross disciplinary interaction between artists and scientists seeks to redefine
the questions or perspectives being asked in research. So we'd love to hear
what you think about the that approach as opposed to the role of the artist
or the photographer as a scientific documentarian.
[Felice] I'm, forgive me. I'm not quite sure.
[Erika] The dialogue between yourself as a science
photographer and research in this process of photography
redefining the questions being asked in the research. That you're not
just observing the science from the outside, your process is a part of-
[Felice] Well,
again,
[Erika] Carolyn, I hope I paraphrased that acceptably.
[Felice] So the,  I'm not, I'm not the artist. So I might be the wrong person to ask this of
because ultimately, for me, it is the science that I want you to look at. I
don't want you, you can if you wanted to think that these, these are artful, but I don't
want that, I, I do have colleagues and friends who
are artists who are, use science as a means of depicting you know their, their
art. This is this is wonderful and I gather, there are, there's a real  symbiosis
that can go on between the artist and the scientist. But that's not
me. And so you'll forgive me, but I can't really make, give you a good answer, maybe
you could talk about that Keith.
[Keith] Yeah, I can in a little bit, but I think that that's
such a wonderful point that you know as a perspective from a photographer, yours
is from the science point of view, even though it translates into oftentimes art.
And I think people confuse it, you have an intention with your photographs.
[Felice] Thank you, yes.
[Keith] And that intention is how you are communicating and visualizing and
that's very, it's wonderful.
[Felice] That is different from the artist.
[Keith] That's right.
[Felice] Who is inspired by the science.
[Keith] Exactly, exactly. And, you know, it shows in what the processes is and what , how people work,
which is very important, from what what vantage point you're coming from for
making your own work on.
[Felice] Yeah, thank you.
[Keith] And then in my instance I often, you know,
I'm collaborating with scientists and I feel very fortunate that I'm with
people who you know, help to tell me or show me what is
important, what is currently happening there. And so we're collaborating a lot to be able to try
and show these things, often they're they're hard concepts to sort of find,
but the the partnership, I find it very stimulating
role in terms of trying to communicate these issues, trying to support work that
they're doing, trying to reach a public. And so I, in some instances, I tried to
transcend a few different roles in the images, sometimes really documenting
something, this is this is what's really happening. Others trying to inspire
people and letting the story of science come through on that. And so, and
sometimes it's several images to sort of convey those, those multiple points
through, but I feel fortunate that helping me, you know, if you look at a
rock and someone points out to you why that rock is of significance and then
you photograph it in a way that's interesting, all of a sudden the story
behind that rock becomes much more meaningful than at first glance looking
at it. And sometimes we get confused with what is a very powerful image with
what is a very powerful image that tells the story that we want to communicate, and they
could be the same, they could be different and lots of variations in
between, but I enjoy that that part of my process.
[Felice] I think, I think one of the
reasons why, I started at MIT over 25 years ago and it's, can't believe it, but
it took a while for the researchers to understand that I was not making my art,
right, that I was working for them. I was serving them. And once they got it, then
we flew, but I am in the service of the research community.
[Erika] I think, I think, you
know, we don't have your collaborating scientists on the line which perhaps was
an oversight on our part, but I imagine a lot of them would say, you know, this
photograph that you took of my research, it helped me think about what I want to
do next in this experiment or how I'm thinking about the science, how I'm
communicating my science. So I think the photographs can also be a tool for
shaping.
[Felice] Absolutely. Thank you for saying that. And I'm told that is in fact the
case, but it's not - But I'm also working on more so now on workshops on graphics.
Because all scientists have to create figures for their journal submissions
and you and it's a collaborative effort we come as a group,
we come together, virtually. And you would be surprised by how thinking about what
it is that they want to say in the figure is a clarification in their own
mind about their science. Thinking about how to visually express it is a means of
clarification, which is what Keith was saying as well.
[Keith] Yeah, I couldn't agree
more. I mean, observation, again, it goes back to
looking at how do you see things. How do you express things and visually
communicating something and I think one of the wonderful things about being at
MIT is that the scientists are also engaging at the forefront of like trying
and experimenting and pushing things. And so it allows both visual stimulation of
how do we show this in a new and exciting way and how do we actually
understand it. And so I find that collaboration to be very, personally
very rewarding.
[Erika] Yeah. Sounds amazing. I think we've got time for one more
question. So I'm going to pull one from the chat, which is, do you ask your co workers
or, and or friends for feedback on your photography or their perspective to see
how you look at it and and the message your audience gets from it? Talk about
the feedback you get on your images.
[Felice] Well, I will tell you.
It's funny how you maybe it's my genetic composition, but you remember the bad stuff. I'll
never forget, I gave a talk in Scotland. It was a big audience. And it was kind of
the beginning of this area of my life and somebody got up in the audience and
said, "you know your your pictures are really ugly." That was the word this
person used. And so you know it threw me back a bit. But I remember that. Whereas I
don't remember what, see I don't really believe what people say now, everybody's
going to say they're nice. I mean, what are they going to say no, they're not nice. Don't
you think Keith?
[Keith] I couldn't agree more. I think you need a close group of colleagues who
can give honest and real feedback. What I like to say is, and I love my mom dearly,
but if I asked her if she likes these pictures I overwhelmingly get these are
wonderful and I love them. But you need real feedback and comments and I think
one of the things is that in terms of teaching photography in art school is,
is trying to get that kind of real feedback. So you learn how to present, you
learn how to sort of articulate and in some ways you hope you get honest
feedback that doesn't just say, I love it, but could you have focused a little more
on this or should you have done this. And I think being hyper critical at least of
myself, I know I'm very hard on myself and with a few people who I really trust
who, to give honest feedback for how to push me harder is what I'm looking
for. And then you know sometimes when you get something right, you know, it just
feels good, but you need that feedback.
[Felice] Keith, you went to photography school? I
don't know that.
[Keith] I gotta, I got a MFA from Parsons.
In Design and Technology and then
now I teach photography both previously at Parsons, and then now currently I
teach photography at SUNY the Fashion Institute of Technology.
[Felice]Do you think, is
this okay Erika for me to ask a question of
Keith?
[Erika] Think so.
[Felice] No, I'm not. I'm not. I'm not trained at all in photography and
I'm,
Do you think you have to be trained in formal training?
[Keith] No, not at all. I think,
I think the thing, I think what formal training does is help you think about
some of the problems that maybe you didn't, and maybe to learn along the way
of and to work through some problems, especially when you're very early in
your career. But I think that the, many some of the most famous photographers I
know, Felice amongst one of them, are not formally trained long at all. But I think
that learning, a lot of people have a natural eye, but then learning to sort of
nurture that and express it is not always something that comes natural and
easy to everyone, and I think school and or courses and workshops can help sort
of begin to give you the vocabulary, begin to give you the things to look at
that can be helpful, instead of spending years of learning how to do something.
Maybe you can learn a little bit quicker. But I think the most important
thing is to understand at least yourself what you're really visually communicating and
what you're really trying to communicate because luck, while it happens only
happens when you really are prepared, I think. Yeah. And so the key is to know how
to make your picture so that if someone asked you to do it, you could really go
out and do it not just be like, oh my god, how am I going to get this image. And
even though that may be how you feel internally. Everyone doesn't need to know like my
own stress of life kind of thing, luckily.
[Erika] Yes, that is excellent insight and so this of
course is the kickoff for a whole program for people to go out and take
images and see the world. So I think what I'd like to do is bring Brian back to
talk a little bit about the logistics of what, what's going to happen on social media
for the next two weeks as we as we flood things and then maybe we'll close out
with one last question.
[Brian] Yeah, thank you so much Felice, Keith and Erika, that's great
conversation. So yeah, as Erika said this is a kickoff to two weeks of Imaging
Science, of encouraging you all to go out, go out in your backyard around your
houses and apartments, and take some pictures and explore and discover through the
lens of photography. So to help you along the way, we have a couple of things
set up for you. So first is we have this hashtag #MITMImagingScience. So if
you follow that hashtag on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram, we're going to be
posting tutorials on macro photography, astro photography, basic camera settings.
There are six tutorials there on a lot of the questions that we actually
we haven't gotten a chance to answer, they're actually going to be answered in
those videos. Whether you use a cell phone or DSLR or whatever camera you
have they're designed to be helpful to help you try a new camera techniques
that you may not have tried before. We're also, would love to see your images.
So along with following that hashtag and seeing some of the resources that we
post please take your own photos, tag them with that hashtag, and at the end of
this program on June 20th we're going to be featuring some of your uploaded
photos as part of that closing webinar.
So with
that I'm going to hand it over to Erika to ask one more question of both of our
panelists.
[Erika] Alright, so my last question is, we've got we've got a several dozen
people out there ready to take photos and I hope many more on social media, who
will watch the recording of this later. So, what's your advice for them? What do
you hope for them as they explore the world with their handheld cameras these
next two weeks and beyond?
[Felice] Do it. Don't think about it, don't ask anybody, should
I do it, just go ahead and shoot. And if you, hopefully you will love it. If you
don't, then don't do it.
Really, it's about life.
[Keith] Couldn't agree
more. And find something that's accessible, don't make a problem, a
photographic problem harder. Don't, you know we can't go anywhere right now,
so photograph something that's right around you and make it really
interesting and what I tell everyone is enjoy the process of photography. For me,
it's a love and I think you really got to find something that you like taking. I
look forward to seeing these images. And so I'm excited to see what you guys
shoot, but really find something you like.
[Felice] I'm going to add one more thing.
Think about, excuse me.
Think about how it looks to someone else. Think about how the viewer is going to
see your picture because you, you know how to look at it and just consider, am I
really showing the first time viewer what it is that I want them to see.
[Erika] Thank
you so much. I wish we could keep talking. But, as you said, it's a beautiful day
outside, and there's a lot of things to discover. So thank you both so
much for being a part of this. Oh and. [Felice] Thank you. [Erika] Our pleasure and thanks Brian for putting it
together, and everybody look for us on #MITMImagingScience